that's a very big question I think we're
going to lose a lot almost whatever we
do because there's so many species right
now that are on the brink of extinction
I mean the brink there are a number of
tree species and flowering plant species
which are known from one individual and
there are bird species for example that
are down to a few dozen individuals we
have two rhinoceros species two out of
the five that existed on the planet that
are 300 individual or fewer left so a
lot of those were going to lose probably
no matter what we do especially those
which we don't even know yet exist and
we may never know they ever existed if
they go extinct before we can learn
enough about the world's biodiversity
but if we plan our use of the
environment in the future intelligently
and drive toward the goal of sustainable
development that is development in that
produces increasing quality of life and
security for people but reduces the
amount of materials and energy that
we're using up and if we intelligently
plan the establishment of reserves where
we get the maximum protection for the
largest number of species and that's one
thing the conservation organizations
like Conservation International which we
have served on the board are devoted
then I think we'll save a majority of
the remaining species
you